[Music]
all right guys um
let's get this show on the road one more
game
let's do this 21 23 we're gonna get a
high-rated opponent
2023.
okay rustia
we're gonna play
okay
well
i feel like sicilian is on the cards
um
all right i have an idea there's a
sicilian line that i haven't played
i think at all in the speed run and it's
one of those lines which i'm sure some
of you have seen before but it often
flies under the radar it's called the
nimesovic sicilian
now you're familiar with knight c6 d6
and e6 but do you know that knight f6
is also a semi-legitimate
variation
obviously the reason it looks very
dubious is precisely because of e5 which
attacks the knight but this is kind of i
would call this an improved version of
the alakan min plays this all the time
so we get essentially an alakan here
with a pawn on c5 and okay he goes c4 so
he's playing this like an alakan but
it's not really going to cut it because
this pawn on c5 is discouraging him from
playing d4
okay so this knight is often tucked away
back to c7 and later it can go out to e6
to contest the center this is pretty
normal and now we just develop normally
okay we should take this pawn
so
we have a couple of ways to go about it
first let's get the knight out to c6 and
contest his centralized knight on d4
as we often do
all right um i believe in my part of the
wood in my part of town
this is called a free pawn
and it's not like the smithmore we we've
developed we've both developed
two of our knights so i don't feel like
white's got significant comp here
this guy doesn't seem very concerned
about it
okay so how should we go about
developing this bishop um what do you
guys think we should do next
should we play d6 e6
i like playing g6 i like g6 a lot if you
encountering because also it defends the
knight on e5 so if he plays bishop f4
with tempo we can still fianchetto okay
he castles so we fiance anyway
and now basically just pawn down for no
comp
we're gonna castle play d6 complete our
development
easy typical stuff
um as we often do in the sicilian in
fact
okay f4
ic6
if he takes the knight we'll have a very
interesting dilemma because
being upon up
makes the option of taking the deep one
quite a bit more tempting
all right so now um
we can castle
um or we can play d6 first i don't think
it
matters particularly
um
start with d6 i guess
just to get this bishop open i'm trying
to discourage i'm a little bit concerned
about f5 although in response to f5 we
can just castle i mean
it doesn't really do anything it's just
sort of sitting there if he takes we
take back
what we didn't want to do is try to win
this pawn by taking the knight because
then we would have to trade our bishop
okay hg
taking toward the center
no need to open up the f-file and give
him extra attacking chances
what is this knight doing here well this
knight could swing around to e6
in order to
put the heat
on this knight on d4 so this knight on
c7 might look bad but it's actually
quite solidly placed if that makes sense
i know some of you have never seen this
placement before but it's not so bad and
it's quite typical for this line for
this knight to kind of lie dormant on c7
until it's ready to go out into the
center
and
to tie this into
a basic principle
we know that not all of your pieces need
to be
climbing everest
or free soloing el capitan at the same
time
um
you know as long as you know that a
piece has a clear path to
improvement
it's okay for that piece to be
temporarily inactive
okay
so knight
f3 that's a really good move he's going
to g5
that's actually an incredibly strong
move
so we have to be careful about how we do
this
i'm definitely scared of queenie one
queen h4 that's
that's the only concerning idea that i
think we have to
properly
deal with
so
let me think
yeah my proposal is that we
try to nip this in the bud by playing
bishop g4
my proposal is that we try to nip this
in the bud
by trading
on f3 as quickly as possible or at least
holding the bishop on g4 he plays queen
d2 which is less scary because
i feel like the maneuver to h4 was more
concerning
but um
if we take an f3 now we allow kind of
the rook lift to h3 so i don't think it
makes sense to take just yet
let's begin by coordinating our rooks
with queen d7 just sort of a
semi-weighting move improving our
position
and we'll see how he decides to proceed
in the mold
we'll make a decision based on it
all right so bishop h6 this is one thing
i'm not too afraid of i don't mind
giving away this bishop
obviously we shouldn't take on h6 and
send the queen in to checkmate us
so what could be a plan here well
it seems like black's position is a
little bit cramped so if we could open
the position up
our extra pawn should make its presence
felt we would also distract white's
attention from the king side
so what could be
a potential plan of opening up our
positional we really only have one
breakthrough which is d5 can d5 be
played immediately well if we count the
defenders it's three on two so clearly
not we should prepare it
and
we should often prepare these pawn
breaks using our pieces
because if we prepare them using our
pawns then
it often defeats the purpose we want to
open up the position to
maximally activate our pieces so rook 88
i think is
a logical follow-up here
and if he goes rook 81 then
perhaps we might have to resort to e6 at
some point okay he takes it
fair enough
knight d4
it's quite surprising to me that he's
choosing to
trade his pieces but there's actually a
super interesting detail after bishop
takes c2
white has a phenomenal tactic that
i think might force at least a draw
so we should be
super vigilant
about how we do this
i actually think best might be
to force this knight out of here
and go e5 that's why we put our queen on
these summons that the bishop on g4 is
defended
the idea of this move e5 is to attack
tonight try to force him to take on c6
which clearly would be in our favor
i'm not
convinced that this is the best move but
we'll see what he what he comes up with
here
yeah you guys can see that these
guys over 2000 are super strong
it's like these are not easy games
he's played well ever since he blunted a
pun
yeah so i think this is
most probably
just good for us so takes takes i like
the way our queen is positioned here
sort of
standing sentinel over the over the
entire king's side and now he's given us
another pawn
now he's given us
another pawn
which we will take
so his play is stagnated we were up two
pawns
and now we're going to use these pawns
and advance them slowly but surely
all right so in such positions i think
people kind of get overwhelmed let's say
you're up two pawns how do you convert
an advantage like this well you need to
prioritize first you need to get your
pieces back to
safe
um
on
you know
invulnerable squares and then you can
worry about
starting to push your pawn so a big
mistake here i think would be to go d5
prematurely the queen on c4 is sort of
stranded
so one move that i really like is just
drop the queen back to e6
and
follow this up with the forbidden move
f6 to cover the g5 square
some of you might be afraid of knight g5
he plays it
it's actually not scary we just drop our
queen to e7 and then we can play
f6 on the next move
as always
you shouldn't be afraid of one move
threats just because it's a one move
threat
this is a very common situation we
invite a move that looks scary but we
realize that
it doesn't actually contain any danger
now we start pushing white's pieces off
of their squares
how do we do this
well
let's start by playing f6 getting rid of
this knight
now d5 is going to be super tempting and
we can definitely play it on the next
move we probably will
so we can decide between playing f5 on
the next move and d5
since our d-pawn is passed i think it
makes a little bit more sense to push
that pawn
pushing f5 weakens the g5 square again
this is after knight f3 so we should
definitely go d5
he's gonna go knight c5 i'm pretty sure
and then i've prepared a nice move
think about what we're gonna do after
knight c5
we have a very nice way to defend
everything and offer another trade
okay knight g3 i'll show this after the
game
okay
so this is a great moment to practice
the art of not hurrying when you're
converting these advantages
i think a lot of people would go e4 here
but e4 gives up the d4 square you don't
want to give up
any counter play any squares
you just want to sort of
gradually convert
you don't need to rush
with any pawn pushes
so one i think great move
uh here is to finally activate this
knight and put it on e6 put it in the
center where it can supervise the
progress of the pawns that h4 one move
threat
he wants to fork
our queen on f5 he's got both knights
eyeing that square
um
how can we defend that square actively
like i don't like king f7 to allow queen
h6 i wanna i want our king to be
firmly placed on g7 so we can go knight
c to d4 yeah
we can go knight c to d4
and then on the next move we can play f5
opening up an attack
on the
h4n so
probably not the best conversion but
i'm not giving him any chances as you
can see
all right
or okay shade achieves the same effect
but
i don't see a reason not to expand
further with f5
knight f3 we take it then we push the e
and d pawns forward
white is white's counterplay is
completely dried up
thank you controls for the seven months
yeah take it
he's
might take with the pawn to try to slow
down the pawns but it's not gonna
achieve the desired effect now he takes
with the rook so he walks right into e4
now we can just push we we've optimized
all of our pieces
um you don't want to rush but you also
don't want to just
waste time
for no reason once
once you're pushing push
as one wise man said
okay so after rook c4 we're going to
make one more
okay rook there never mind
thank you
okay so if we really want to put our
karpov hat on
the russian
the move that the russians would teach
you to play you know the move that the
russians would teach you to play is
asics
don't even give a single pawn like do
not give
a single inkling of a chance inc and why
do you do something like this because i
think the logic is if things go
catastrophically wrong
if you play with sufficient um with a
sufficient safety net you're essentially
going to ensure that nothing bad can
happen in the long run
um now we can continue pushing e3
and once he sinks this queen into d3 we
can smoke the queen out using our knight
knights are very good at smoking
um pieces out of these kinds of squares
now we couldn't go knight f4 that's why
he presumably put his rook there but we
have c5
and now we're basically ready to push
our d-pawn and
start
you know
the final innovation
yeah i don't see why not
thank you louis for the prime
e2 is coming followed by d2
there comes a point at which you don't
even really care about keeping the
knight
you could even sacrifice it if it means
you promote one of your pawns
well i'm getting stiffer resistance as
you guys can see there's there's a
couple of nerve-wracking moments in most
of these games it's not
the smoothest but
yeah now e2
counter attacking the rook
yeah e2 is very very easy
we're threatening both he takes f1
check as well as e1 queen which is
actually the bigger threat notice that
e1 equals queen is the bigger threat
because if he takes that queen
well then we take the rook and it's
backrank mate whereas if you take the
rook
that's that just wins a rook
the funny thing is
yeah he'll he's probably going to take
here but then we just take with the pawn
opening up the d file and we can invade
with the rook
so the position plays itself essentially
here
yeah so d e
and now swooping into d1 he probably
thinks queen c3 gives him some chances
but it doesn't
this is
very very typical if he takes on e2 we
just take back
the fact that the rook is pinned means
that he can never take on e2
yeah this was a nice game
yeah okay now how should we win the game
what what's the winning move here
the logic here is that the queen defends
the rook so if we can get this queen out
of c3 at any cost it's immediate
checkmate
so it doesn't matter how we do it
yeah except rook d4
all right i don't want to hear the move
i'm even hovering over the right piece
queen f6
this isn't about trading queens
okay so he continues to
flap around here we're going to go
knight e4 if he doesn't want to take my
knight i'm going to use it to get his
queen out of the way
yeah
good game
okay i think it's time to resign
yeah there's definitely been a bit of a
lull um
of late but
it's all good
cool
so
i'm not going to talk too much about
this opening
um i do want to round off the stream but
yeah names of sicilian is something to
investigate if you're in the market for
something a little bit more offbeat
the
the you know white white can play e5
white can also play knight c3 and here
the nims of which way is to play d5
this leads to one of the most unique
structures very unsicilian like you
don't get these structures in the
sicilian almost ever
and although white can get a slight
advantage in a variety of ways it's
it's honestly not such a bad opening
and
um if if white is not precise i've seen
you know black at really nice positions
out of the opening you can check out min
splits games he does
super super well
he does super super well in these types
of positions
um
okay so
[Music]
e5 knight d5 and the move c4 is already
inaccurate
in this position i believe knight c3
is considered to be
the main move and black plays e6 here
trying to anchor the knight
and you got you have this weird line
where white captures and plays d4
there's a lot of theory here there's a
pawn sack line super cool
there's like a double pawn sack line
that goes like this i'm sure you'll find
men's games in this position
so you guys can do your own research
here
but
you can trust me that this is not such a
bad line it's something to add to your
arsenal if you're looking for something
offbeat
so he goes c4
which is positionally speaking not very
good now the bishop is blunted
um d4 cd knights e4 knight c6 so i'd say
the position is about equal
um but white should just take the knight
and play knight c3
g6 oh sorry not f6 g6
and we get a position i mean this is
just a position
um i think black is totally fine here
eventually we're going to go d6 and
break down the spawn chain so i quite
like
black's position here
but this is definitely better than what
he did knight c3 just blunders upon
so this definitely shows that even very
strong players when faced with
unfamiliar opening territory they tend
to
they tend to falter up until the level
of 22 2300s even if they think that
they're playing naturally
so bishop e2 it's called the nimzovic
sicilian g6
castles bishop g7
this stretch was very obvious we're just
developing our pieces
castles
ghg knight f3 which was a really nice
move
and we decided on bishop g4
um
yeah so to understand this move you got
to understand that white wants to get
the knight to g5 and eventually the
queen to h4 which is quite a dangerous
plan so we're just trying to nip that in
the bud
by
creating the possibility of trading the
knight
if he goes knight g5 here
then i was thinking of actually taking
and as ugly as it seems we do have the
move f6
and here the knight on c7 actually turns
out to be excellently placed because he
can't go knight e6
so notice that even these kinds of
pieces they have their merits
why hg6 instead of fg6 well fg6 weakens
the e6 square
and i wasn't sure that the open f-file
favors black because we don't have our
rooks coordinated yet
so i feel like he's going to essentially
take on f8 and bring the other rook to
f1 so we might give white the f file and
that's not something i want to concede
okay so bishop g4 queen e27
bishop h6 or kd8
takes and i i think here he started
i think this stretch he misplayed very
severely
um
i think the best move is rook 81 he's
got to stop me from going d5
and
we can even consider playing e5 here and
trying to secure the d4 square for our
knight
this knight on c7 again is the hero
because it defends
the square on d5 doesn't allow y to
access this outpost
um
so i think we often think of
you know evaluating pieces based on how
they look or how many squares they
control what we don't think about is
pieces that occupy a defensive role but
those pieces can be super valuable just
a piece that
whose only go whose only role is to
defend a particular square that can be a
very valuable assignment so
don't rush to assume that a knight on c7
like this is extremely passive or bad it
can actually make your position tick
so king g7 knights e4 and i think e5 is
really really strong
this forces white's hand
and essentially leads to highly
undesirable trades
um
what was wrong with bishop dxe2 well the
engine is laughing at me but i thought
knight f5 check
leads to a draw by perpetual apparently
it doesn't
and the reason it doesn't is because
after gf actually no now
yeah queen g5 check
and black and go king h7 and i forgot
that this square is defended
this is a classic miscalculation i
forgot that this bishop still is alive
but apparently rook four makes a draw no
i was right
rook f4 leads to a draw
because rook is swinging to h4 we have
to intercept it
white sacks the exchange getting rid of
the bishop and now this is perpetual
so very nice line and i did end up
evaluating this correctly this is a draw
takes queen g5
not queen h5 but rather workout four and
i could sense that this was not worth
going for when we had plenty of other
options
so e5 takes takes essentially the game
is already over he's down upon he's
losing another one
i suppose white should take and go b3
but now our pawns start rolling again
and
we win in a very similar way to the game
so
and the rest of once we grab the second
pawn the rest is easy we centralize our
queen we push the knights away
we centralize our own knight
we defend against that f5 and then we
push all of our pawns until
he resigns essentially
so
very straightforward conversion
not not a super complicated game but i
think it clearly shows
how
you know first of all the power of
playing these kinds of offbeat openings
and then also
um
patiently identifying your opponent's
source of activity also you can see the
knight on c7 which played a pretty
important role in this game even though
it sat there for a long time
all right guys i'm tired i'm gonna call
it a day
um more stuff coming your way tomorrow
but
i'm gonna hit the sack and i'll see you
guys later thanks for hanging out i
really appreciate your support
throughout the tournament
good night guys
[Music]